okay
so good afternoon everyone let's get
going so we have lecture number 15 of
the
course and as is customary with me let's
do a very short intro of what we have
learn so far so again we are with the
problem of operator learning so this is
the abstract
pde and this is the solution operator
which is given here which takes as input
uh coefficients a and sources F and
turns out the solution here and we know
that because the inputs and outputs of
functions we have to work with this
notion of continuous discrete
equivalence otherwise we will not be
learning the actual mapping that takes
functions to functions we'll only be
learning a certain F dimensional
representation and again I repeat this
notion of Reno or representation
equivalent neural operator which is that
you have an operator that Works between
functions and functions and the way you
go is you go down to some grid by a
suitable encoding Point values for
instance if you have band limited
functions you do your processing there
and then you come back through some
reconstruction this is some form of
interpolation because from point values
you have to read back the function and
as long as this diagram commutes then we
are we are okay right and while using
this perspective we did some analysis
and we found that
some of them are not Renos some of them
are Renos and so on and in the last
lecture we focused almost exclusively on
CNO on relution neural operator and we
discovered that it has some desirable
theoretical properties and it also works
well in practice right so let me just
start with that and try
to so remember that this is your CNO and
the essential bits of CNO where the two
operators convolution and nonlinearity
and both of them had this nice feature
that they were Ros so you have this is
the this the convolution K here which is
the and then you have the nonlinearity
which is given here so in particular you
have to use this upsampling and down
sampling operations in order to in order
to preserve the band limits in order to
have this reeno properties and so on and
in practice what we ended up was with a
operator unit which had this look or
this sort of a multiscale information
processing so you took in information um
lifted it then sort of reduce the
resolution increase the number of
channels kept on doing that in this sort
of structure preserving manner in the
encoder part so this was roughly the
encoder and there is also a decoder
which is on the other side and we will
see also more and more all sort of uh
Vision State ofth art Vision processes
machine learning algorithms they have
this sort of multiscale feature this is
an important part of the whole thing
because it allows for multiscale
information
processing and uh we showed uh through
various examples that it is it has it is
also good
performance some cases it doesn't do
better than this is what I did not point
out in the last lectures for instance if
you take alen K equation which is a
nonlinear parabolic equation UT is
roughly U1 - U ^ 2 plus some Kion of U
so you have some reaction which is given
by these terms here or 1 minus U I
forgot the exact form of the
nonlinearity and you have some diffusion
which is given by this term here here
for instance okay the errors were small
but f o was still
competitive remember so this was this
was one example in general there were
both these approaches are fairly
competitive and what we should remember
is that the main differentiation between
them to some extent comes from the fact
that one is a Reno so if you had error
versus Grid so in one case you more or
less got a flat one and the other case
you got a something like this so this
was sort of the behavior that they had
and this was sort of the major
differentiator between them otherwise
they are sort of roughly comparable to
each other and one depending on the
problem that you have one might do
better on a fixed grid and the other
might do better on another grid okay so
now what is so this is uh so far so good
now the starting point of my lecture
today is to point out some of the
obvious limitations with these
approaches okay and to that extent I
have identified three issues that we are
going to discuss in some detail today
the week after and the week after so
that you get a comprehensive
understanding of where things then for
the first point uh which you could have
guessed and I think I said it is that
both fno and CNO and many of other
algorithms that I mentioned some of the
other algorithms that I mentioned they
there sort of principle even though they
don't need it but their principal mode
of operation is always on regular okay
so in other words uh the
data the inputs and outputs and the
processing always happens on a regular
something like this right so this is
sort of the so this is what uh you allow
for which is okay right in many problems
we have that structure certainly if you
have images images are always in the
form of squares or rectangles so it's
it's no problem but in reality we in
scientific Computing in particular
remember that we even had the the
example of the air foil right so we had
the example of the air foil so certainly
the domain there is not a rectangle even
though we reduced it by some masking if
you remember in the last lecture I had
pointed it out right so but this can be
an issue if you have very very
complicated grids so at the moment uh at
least the way we have have learned it
fno CNO fno for instance you can do it
on General grids but then you don't have
the efficiency of the fast FIA transform
remember the fast FIA transform was the
key because we had to transform things
in fua domain right so fno or CNO they
in out of out of the box they don't
allow for let's say irregular grds for
instance this a lactus which is tensor
product of two sort of regular grids in
each Dimension and these are random
points for instance if you have random
sensor locations so in order to operate
with this you have to do some form of
interpolation in other words you have to
take data here get back here take data
here get back here which is what we did
with this masking strategy right so we
had data which was generated on points
in this domain and then what we did is
that we interpolated it onto a regular
Grid or we just projected it onto a
regular grid and put a mask you know to
denote the boundary
so there are some work arounds and I
think if I get time so in a couple of
weeks I'll probably revisit this topic
but this is this is this could be an
issue the second problem and the third
problem they're actually related to each
other to some extent and I will deal
with them in some detail so the second
problem is that of time dependent PDS
okay so what are time dependent PDS so
if you remember in the last lecture for
instance we had this example from the sh
so the idea there was that that we
started with some initial data you will
see some examples uh later today we
started with some initial data and then
the operator simply predicted the
solution at a later time step right so
you had some vertices which were shed so
this was at a later time step in other
words you started with u0 and you
finished at U but remember the time
dependent problems they have some
natural sort of a data availability or
data the natural form of them is really
in the form of a video you can think of
it as a video you can think of it as a
trajectory you can think of it as a
sequence of images so there is some
information on time right so this is
what we we will look at in some detail
today and somehow intimately related and
even more important is the issue of
scaling with data so let me try to just
explain it a little bit and we are going
to talk at some length about this today
and next week we're going to focus on
this issue quite a lot so this is
exactly the same problem as before
remember this uh nav Stokes sheer layer
problem so the task is to just predict
the solution at time t equal to 1 given
the initial data so I'm taking out the
time information completely I'm saying
okay you give me an initial condition
and I'll will churn out the solution at
a certain time this is the setup right
now what I did here is that we took
three modeles uh CNO fno the number of
parameters are sort of comparable one is
more than the other but shouldn't this
not a big issue here and we also took
some Transformer model can transform
something some of the early attempts of
using Transformers in this domain and
the questions that we asked are very
simple that we train the model with X
number of training samples what is the
training sample here this is this pair
here right so you start with some
initial data you start with some initial
data and you go to the final solution so
this is uh so we start with so we have
for here means we have 2 ,000 4,000
6,000 8,000 and so on WE increase the
number of training samples and we want
to see how the error decays so the idea
is as you give more data you should get
better results right so this is roughly
the idea that we operate with and you
see that this is actually happening
there is very little Theory regarding
this you know this is what people
believe there is very in fact I was the
only one with some results in this
direction I maybe I get some time to
describe them in next week but uh
there's very little Theory but what we
observe is that there is some what is
called scaling right so this is this is
a key issue in machine learning so you
have some scaling what do I mean by that
the best way is to look at a log log
plot so here you have the log of the
number of training
samples and here we have the log of the
we have the errors so it's a semi logog
right so as you can see now what we do
is that we increase the number of
samples it goes all the way from 512 no
256 5
12,24 248 496
8,192 you see that in all the cases we
have some scaling right in other words
as you increase the number of samples
the total amount of data that the system
is ingesting you see that the
performance in terms of the error gets
better and better and better some more
samples there there are some bottlenecks
here and the bottle size is going to be
a bottleneck we'll talk about that later
but assuming that we have a model that
trains you see that this is the test
error and the test error goes down in a
predictable manner right it goes down in
a predictable manner in this case the
rate is roughly
1/3 so if you have eight orders of
magnitude more samples which is eight is
difficult to say because I don't have
eight orders of magnitude here but five
orders of magnitude you can see that it
goes from 8 to 13 and the error goes
from like 4 and 1 half% to approximately
1% so the it's some between 0.33 and 0.5
right because uh if it would have
reduced by 2 and a half times you would
have seen that it would be 0.5 but it
did not so it's it's roughly in that
ballp so there are some predictable
scaling laws of course in this
particular case we see that uh somehow
CNO does better than it we also saw that
with a fixed number of samples but it
does better than the other models fno
and the galin Transformer these are very
very comparable to each other but this
one is better even double is better
right so as you can see here it's
roughly 1% and this is like 2% 1% and 2%
but what is interesting is that you see
the amount of data that is necessary
right because uh okay this is not the
hardest problem on Earth but even to get
1% error here whatever 1% means some
number that we fix some desired level of
accuracy you see that we need about
8,000 samples and this is expensive
right each of this is a CFT simulation
uh it takes some time we have very fast
code so this can be done fast but in
general in reality you don't have that
Advantage right so each simulation can
take let's say 10 minutes in 2D and then
you have 8,000 of these that's that's
too much so it's already the the fact
that you need data there is scaling with
data but it tells you that if you give
more and more data you get better and
better results but how much of data is
enough and what kind constraints you
have with data because the difference in
scientific Computing and imaging is
different right we see in images you
just Cote the internet and you try to
take all the stock images and but here
we don't have that we don't have that uh
Advantage so one has to think a little
bit about data and so this is intimately
related in time dependent problems
because how do things scale with data
because as you can see in time dependent
problems we'll have some more data than
we expected in in some sense this is
what I'm going to teach you but but is
the issue of scaling clear that this is
an important consideration arguably the
most important consideration and this is
what I will really focus on in the next
next lecture but today let's focus on
the time dependent problems that's
that's that's the main content so now
let me start with some abstract form
because then notation becomes easier so
you start with
U this is the abstract form of the PD I
have taken a first derivative but you
know that first derivative time here but
you know that second derivative is no
problem because you can always reduce a
second derivative into a first
derivative or third derivative into
first derivative by considering systems
okay uh this this L here is your
differential
operator this is a differential
operator and if you want to think of a
concrete model you can think of UT minus
some of U equal to Z the heat equation
right and the initial condition tion is
of course uar some function so the idea
is that we are what we interested is in
the solution operator so this is heat
equation a Strokes compressible oil
equations Salen wave equation whatever
you want is in this format question no
sorry okay so then what is the what is
the target here what do we want to learn
is a solution operator s and how is it
defined so now you have the initial
conditions because this determine the
the trajectory this determine the the
evolution but you also have the time
right the time is a continuous variable
so what you do is that you supply the
time you supply the initial conditions
and you know what is a PD then you know
the solution at a later time right so
it's a it's a causal problem you can
always March forward and drive okay
backward and drive is not always
Possible only in reversible systems so
now in particular what we know is that
we can substitute this this solution
operator is having something called a
semigroup
property
semigroup and the idea is that if you so
let's say that you have done the
evolution and you can start at a
different time and you move further and
you get back the same solution so this
is what causality is and what it means
is that you can also put in the time
increment here so let's say that you're
starting at perhaps it's good to do some
geometry so let's say that you have a
solution trajectory I'll just show it in
1D mean not as a video but let's say
that this is a solution trajectory
something like this for instance a
solution of an OD right and this is your
U this is your U so if you start at u0
and you supply t plus delta T you will
reach this point here or you start at UT
and you ask what is the increment in
delta T you'll also reach the same point
right so this is a cality that whether I
start at the beginning and go towards
the end time or whether I start very
close to the end time and GL to a same
time provided that the time increment is
given as a as one of the parameters then
we know that the solution can be
generated and is unique so this is this
is causality this means that because it
is causal and we are going to exploit
that in a in some manner what happens is
that the data that you generate or the
data that you record the data that you
observe is often in the form of
trajectories so what is a trajectory
what is the meaning of a trajectory
trajectory is not just the value at one
particular time but it's like a video so
you in principle you could have the
value at all possible times but of
course that would be continuous we can't
store continuous things on a computer so
you have to put some sampling so it's a
collection of time snapshots with the
causal Arrow being there me in the sense
that at time t equal to 1 then time t
equal to 2 time t equal to 3 and so on
so in other words you have been given so
again I need to draw some pictures here
so this is time and just imagine at each
time you'll get an image right or a
video in general so then you just choose
certain sampling points in time so this
is t0 T1 T2 T TK in general right and
then T capital K is equal to capital T
this need not be uniformly spaced okay
this can be whatever your recording
instrument your camera or your numerical
simulation whatever this need not be
equally spaced of course the equally
spaced one is the easiest one so what
you get are this entire set of values so
just imagine that you have all these
images in the form of a video and this
has a certain sampling rate right so
this is the way you can think of it and
this is of course Given In terms it's
all determined by the initial condition
so given the initial condition and given
these lead times T1 T2 and so on in
principle we should be able to generate
them so the data that is given there is
uh having this particular format right
you could also generated using
increments but that is a that so for
instance you can go from u0 you can go
to U1 and then from U1 you go to U2 then
you go to u3 go to T4 and so on and so
forth and when you do numerical
simulations yes go ahead we have
already signal
this because starts from zero forward
that right only if you have time
dependent if you have a signal that is
static but it's a function of space then
there is no causality so the specificity
here is the fact that time provides you
a direction if you don't have the
direction there is no reason why you
can't go just imagine that in this room
I can always walk from here to there
there to here and come back but I can't
go to 10 minutes later and come back so
this is where the causality is is the
key so time has this causal property
forces causality and one has to one has
to Recon with it okay so now remember
that the data is always in the form of
trajectories let's imagine that we
trying to generate data we want to go
and do a numerical simulation we take
the initial conditions and we do a
numerical simulation right the numerical
simulation automatically as a Time
stepping so you generate um a delta T to
delta T and so on and so forth you don't
want to store all of it because
otherwise it will be too big you have to
sample so let's say that you store at
tal to 0 tal to 0.1 0 two and so on and
so forth so out of a numerical
simulation you will get a trajectory
this trajectory would have some sampling
frequency let's say that there are K
samples in it or your video has a
resolution of one over K so you have k k
frames in the video right so this is
these are the two ways you can think
about it and this is the data set always
contains that you have to store it of
course the computational cost is exactly
the same because in order to compute
later you have to compute in the
beginning all these uh numerical methods
that we also talked about these are Time
marching methods so there's no choice
but you have this information and you
put them together you store them so
there is a cost of storage but you
always have information in the form of
trajectories if you this is the language
of physics in the language of computer
science this will be videos okay so you
have trajectories and you have videos so
what is the learning task for a Time
Depend and this is very important right
because in a Time dependent problem it
is not just given an initial condition
and you read of the solution at a final
time because the data that is used to
generate this probably has information
about the trajectories and this is
something that we we need to leverage
because remember more data is better why
is that remember this particular graph
right so more data is always better is
the somehow the principle of machine
learning so what is the what is the
learning task learning task which I
wrote in text here is very simple given
the initial conditions and the boundary
conditions domain efficients and so on
all the other material properties of the
medium you have to generate the whole
ideally because this is what a numerical
simulation does you have to generate the
solution trajectory for all times okay
at least for uh the times that you want
to sample you should be able to generate
that so in a way this is a hard T you
have data but our task is also hard so
what I'm asking now is that if I given
the initial conditions if I'm given the
boundary conditions the domain and so on
I should be able to predict the solution
for all times in the future because that
is what the solution of the PD does so
this is harder than what we had seen
before which was given the initial
conditions I wanted a solution at a
certain time now I'm asking something
which is a harder question that I also
need some continuity in time in the
sense that I time itself is going to be
a continum now often this issue and this
is important to make a remark here that
this issue is when people come from
computer science and try to do these
simulations they they don't necessarily
operate within this framework they say
no no give me 20 TR 20 values of the
trajectory and then I'll predict the
next value and so they always assume
that there is some stream of data that
is coming in and they have to keep on
completing the stream you see so for
instance just imagine the weather data
in principle I have access to the
weather 6 hours before 12 hours before
18 hours before 24 hours before and so
on and I could use these guys to make
the prediction for the next six hours
this is this is always possible but this
is very special and it's only possible
for uh like weather data data weather is
streaming happening in general this is
not the situation that we are going to
work with because in general when you
have to generate data for a Time
dependent problem you have to generate
it from the initial conditions like a
numerical simulation does you know so
what is the point of having a numerical
solver for the first 50 times steps and
then making the 51st or the 52nd time
this is uh there many people do that I
think % or 90% of the papers that are
written in this field they assume that
there is trajectory data because they're
basing everything on the weather but
this is a very very specific domain in
general you don't have access to that
right you are going to design something
you have to set up your numerical solver
and that setup costs are very very large
so what you would ideally want is that
you give me the car and I should read
off the flow field you see or give me
the material and I should read off how
the temperature field spreads so you
should always remember that there is
this distinction here which is very very
important so for us we are going to be
in the exact situation as a numerical
solver which is if you're given the
domain you're given all the coefficients
you're given the boundary conditions
given the initial conditions you march
forward in time okay and so we want to
replicate exactly this problem is this
clear the difference between streaming
data and the sort of learning task that
I have set here which is harder because
you don't have access you only have
access to initial conditions and then
you have to learn okay so this is an
important point that I wanted to mention
now how how do you do that right so now
we have this and how does neural
operators what do they do for instance
what you have learned so far with fno
and CNO how how is this done right well
it can't be done because the way fno CNO
the way I have introduced them for
you you don't have that you so so far
what we have is that you have a new
operator it can n it could be CNO fno
whatever it takes let's say the initial
conditions and it produces a solution at
a later time and to train it you are
exactly using the same kind of initial
conditions right you always give an
image and then you produce the solution
at a later time so of course uh no one
stops me from predicting the solution so
what one could do is I could take the K
neural operator actually some people
even do that I can take the K neural
operator and its task is given the
initial conditions I produce a solution
at the K time level so the ne operator
one will produce it at the first time
level you'll operate a two will'll do it
at the second time level third time
level and so on and so forth then you
can use whatever we have right because
okay it's just a fixed time prediction I
just have what I have and I just plug it
in now what is the issue with that as
you can see then we have too many models
right we have to run capital K different
neural operators and and this is not not
the best uh computational investment
particularly if you want a continuous
evaluation right because then in that
case maybe we need 100 neural operators
to be able to represent the temporal
variation so this by itself is not going
to be enough for sure and in particular
as I said it only gives you discrete
time levels it's very expensive and it
does not give you some data advantages
in the sense that uh I just let's say I
I have the trajectory but I'm not using
the trajectory I'm simply using the fact
so I'm not using the fact that it's a
Time Evolution at all I'm using I'm
taking my initial condition and
producing the solution at time one and
this is completely unrelated to taking
my initial condition and producing the
solution at time two I could have used
the solution at time one to predict the
solution at time two this is not being
done in this naive approach right so if
you want to take something out of the
box apply fno o this is a way to go but
this is very very inefficient and no one
does it right so this is just out of the
means out of the starting point the
starting block itself this can be thrown
out but this is the so we have to
somehow introduce time into the scheme
otherwise it does not work so what
people do is what I say next that they
use what is called an auto regressive
maybe you have seen this before Auto
regressive evaluation what does it mean
means okay this is a
simplification it's a reasonable simplif
well actually you need it in this
particular case so the main assumption
here is that you have uniformly spaced
time
points okay let's say that we have that
just like we had regular grids we could
have uniformly spaced time points and
then the data is given at this uniformly
spaced time points let me draw a picture
so you have the initial condition you
have the next time point the next time
point the next time point the next time
point and so on right so what is uh what
does it do so what the neural operator
does and as I said many many what you
can give if o c whatever the what what
do what do you do or CNN whatever you
have is that you give it you make it
predict the next frame so this in
computer science this is called Next
frame
prediction because now the delta T is
fixed right I I know what the Delta is
the delta T is not in so the delta T is
the direction here so what I'm going to
do is that I have um I I just predict
I'm able to predict the next frame
similarly from here to here I can
predict the next frame from here to here
I can predict the next frame from here
to here I can predict the next frame so
given the initial conditions if I want
to come to this point what am I going to
do at inference is I start with my with
my neural operator I predict the next
frame first so I go from here to here
that's a neural operator then I use that
predict the next frame so it's like a
marching scheme then I use that further
I predict the next frame use that
further I predict the next frame so by
using it four times this is what is auto
regressively so also in language when
people model text for instance they
model a token by token roughly word by
word right so they say I then there's I
am then something else and something
else so it uses that context right so
this is common in language it's also in
scientific Computing it's a very very
easy way so all that you're doing is
that you're predicting the increment of
the solution to the next time step okay
and uh so this is so this is exactly
what I what I just said in formulas this
is exactly this that if you want to
predict a Time TK so what you have to do
is to apply it one time then two times
and you have to do this K times so if
you do it tively then you have able to
evaluate okay is this clear now so the
this kind of Auto regressive evaluation
you just keep on feeding the neural
operator again and again and again okay
so this seems like a very attractive uh
we will see some numerical examples
later this seems like a very attractive
way of doing it uh unfortunately and
many many people do it so this is the
most common way in which neural networks
are trained and uh for time dependent
problems but there are several caveats
here right so first of all you need some
uniform spacing because it is agnostic
to the value of the increment right it
says that there are equal increments so
you learn something second is that you
always have and this this process here
is called a roll out right roll out is
simply I have a trained neural operator
which has learned to predict the next
frame or the next time step so I just
give the solution the initial condition
and I roll it out I take I apply it once
it'll give you a value I apply it twice
it'll give a value and so on and so
forth uh but when you do long rollouts
particularly training remember at the
end of the day we have to train these
objects also right so the back
propagation algorithm has to take you
back to the initial time otherwise how
else are we going to do the computation
so while you do back propagation this is
called back propagation through time
bptt uh if you have lots lots of roll
outs then the gradient you know that
each step the gradient changes so if the
gradient is less than one if you do it
50 times you know you can get zero
gradient and if you it's a gradient is
is greater than one then it flows up so
it's sort of you end up with these
problems that you have due to exploding
and Vanishing radient so this is an
important element that's why this you
can't sort of do long roll outs during
training so during training necessarily
you have to do this a whole field how to
do this efficiently I don't have the
time to go into the details but
essentially what you do is that you can
only train for shorter rollouts in the
sense that you take three roll outs and
try to match the solution or you take
four roll outs and you try to match the
solution the problem is at inference you
might need to do it 50 times and this is
where this could be an issue but the of
course it's also evaluation only at the
discrete time levels we cannot predict
continuously in time but the biggest
issue here is error accumulation and
what is the meaning of
that so let me without writing in
formulas let me try to explain it in
words what error accumulation is so
remember that we are trying to solve a
Time dependent problem okay so of course
uh we start with the initial conditions
and the solution at a later time is
going to be very different from the
initial conditions provided that you
wait long enough right for longer times
just imagine the weather now and the
weather it was in Monday for instance
the Sunday Sunday was 28° and today is
2° right so as we waited long we saw
that there was a huge change but of
course if you would have taken the
weather at on Sunday and predicted to
6:00 a.m. on Monday then this would
would have been a much easier prediction
because there is some continuity there
right so now just imagine that you have
learned only this is this a cartoon of
course but you have learned only sort
let's say summer weather and uh so you
have made the small predictions it's
okay when you do short-term predictions
and now you have to compose it again and
again and again just imagine that if you
had have used weather till for from last
week because last week was very warm you
would have managed to predict the
weather quite accurately on Monday but
then if you kept on using the same
operator again and again and again of
course uh there is a obvious uh mismatch
here right there is an obvious error so
as you try to predict for longer you are
going to get error accumulation because
you're making the same operator run
again and again and again of course you
could have avoided it by during the
training process having this but then
you have the issue with the long
rollouts that the training is half so
this is as I said means this is a very
very common strategy people use use it
all the time but it has its uh let's say
its drawbacks right it has this these
kind of issues so you'll see that this
is not exactly this error accumulation
is what makes this um basically
unfeasible so we need we need to come up
with an alternative and this is uh what
I'm going to describe very quickly and
also in the next lecture I'll give you
some more details which is called and
it's not the only issue it's not just an
accumulation we also wanted a continuous
output right we wanted to be able to
evaluate uh the solution operator
probate at any point so what do we do
it's called time conditioning means it's
it's uh it's it's fairly recent but
there are some couple of papers
including ours in this direction so let
me
describe and for instance when I taught
it last year we did not have this so
this it's a very fast moving field so
the idea is very simple that we should
evaluate and also in terms of data if
you remember that the amount of data
that you have you you are restricted by
the fact that now you exactly have K
frames right because you're predicting
the next frames so you're predicting the
next frame so you have exactly K frames
in some sense and then what we do in
this lead time conditioning or time
conditioning is time itself just like in
the solution operator time itself should
be in the input right so it should be an
additional Channel it should be in the
input that's already some advantage
because then it allows you to have
continuous in time outputs so you take
CNO for instance or fno for that matter
it does not really matter this is
agnostic to the model so what you could
do the first element is that you could
give the time lead time as it is called
the time to focus you can give it as an
input in other words Your solution
operator takes time and it takes the
initial conditions of the previous image
and it turns out the solution at a later
time okay and this is usually added it
as an additional Channel because
remember that I have already temperature
pressure velocity whatever so I can
always add time as an additional Channel
and then after that so this in some
cases this is sufficient because now you
have access to a richer amount of data
because in principle you can say that I
can start with the initial conditions
and predict up to 0.1 I have the data
for that I can start with the initial
conditions and I can predict up to 0.2 I
have data for that and so on and so
forth but in this form it does not
really work because uh this is too
little an input because what happens is
these networks have lots of layers right
and by the time you go to the 10th layer
the fact that you time as an initial
layer or as an initial input is
forgotten you know because you have to
somehow process the time you have to
keep it uh as a as a running input
somehow right and this is done by using
what are called conditional
normalizations so let me explain this
and maybe in the next lecture I give you
a little bit more detail because we are
and you're running out of time so what
are conditional
normalizations so remember that in
machine learning and this you have
learned also in your practicals in your
tutorials that you need normalizations
there are batch normalizations instance
normalizations layer normalizations and
so on and the idea is very simple that
before you do the processing so you take
the let's let's take a concrete example
here let's take CNO for instance so
let's say that you do the processing
here you get a out outut let's say the
output is W another image right so what
you do is you normalize W because also
the inputs are normalized because
otherwise machine learning doesn't work
the gradients will have very different
scales and you can't frame so you
normalize the way in which normalization
works in general is that you take
some normalization means that you take
your current input to the
layer you take some uh mean some
expected value this could be over the
batch
it could be over the layer means all the
outputs to the layer it could be over
the instance and so on there are
different kinds of normalizations I will
tell the bo Victor and ban to talk about
it perhaps in one of the tutorials
there's no time for the details here but
it's essentially some form of
normalization right so once you do the
normalization of course you take out the
you take out the you take out the mean
and then you sort of divide by the
variance or divide by the standard a so
you want to get things back within minus
one one or 01 minus one one in this
particular case right just and this was
the key trick by which machine learning
deep learning architectures work because
without batch normalization and layer
normalization they were simply not
working so you anyway have to do this
depending on the architecture that you
have like for CNO you use batch
normalization for Transformers it's
layer normalization and so on so there
is this normalization that happens for
the input to each layer okay first you
process normalize process normalize
process and so on and the idea behind
this is why don't we leverage the fact
that we have these normalizations to
keep on giving time as an input okay
because so that the effect of time is
not forgotten so instead of just giving
time once here you also give time here
you give time here you give time here
here here here everywhere so roughly
that is the idea and what you what we do
is that we just modify the
normalizations we simply introduce um
learnable functions so this could be
neural networks but in general these are
really so GN of T is typically some
Matrix GN t plus some G hat and some
Vector okay so this is a a fine function
but it could be MLP some small Neal
Network and what you do is that this
gives the effect of time as I said here
it gives the effect of time at every
input more or less so every layers
remember
that it is doing something for this
particular time step or for this
particular time instant okay and it's
obvious how you normalize it because how
you initialize it because this guy
should be close to one and this guy
should be zero at initialization but of
course these are learnable mappings so
they are going to learn what is the
effect of the time for this particular
layer at uh this particular input right
so this is roughly what what what the
idea is so you have to give time as some
sort of a conditioner so that you
condition your the output of your model
on the time okay so is this uh the the
details about how I take the expected
value is not important here okay so this
this could be that now all the neurons
in that given layer produce some outputs
and you could just average over them or
it could be some other kind of some sort
of an average okay think of this as some
sort of an average so that you normalize
between minus and one one and one
and then you're going to modulate this
average by this time dependent functions
so theistic that you should remember is
that in addition to feeding it as the
input value I'm also going to feed it uh
during all all layers so this is sort of
the basic humanistic of this lead time
conditioning and I've really run out of
time today I was slower than usual but
in on Wednesday what I'm going to do is
that okay so now we have this uh so the
time dependent C know what does it do it
has this additional layers additional
inputs and additional layers and the
same with FN means all all architectures
can be modified because all of them use
some form of normalization so you give
the input in the input Channel time and
you give this within each layer so now
we have this let's a new architecture
how are we going to train it how we
going to leverage the data and so on and
this is going to be the task of the next
lecture because if I start the next
slide I will not be able to finish it so
I don't want to rush it okay so on
Wednesday we start with this and then we
go towards the issue of scaling and
Transformers okay so let's let's stop
here